[Music]
the Clank of heavy metal bars echoing
through the building usually kept Avi up
at night but he never thought that he
would ever come to miss that sound one
day as he tossed and turned in his
uncomfortable bunk he couldn't help that
the noise reminded him of how confined
he was and how trapped he felt within it
had been a mistake an honest and
completely unpredictable mistake on the
nights that sleep evaded him he'd always
replayed the events over and over again
his daughter Callie calling him out of
the blue her distorted uncontrollable
sobs playing into his ear over the phone
Avi remember jumping into the car and
flooring the accelerator rain drumming
against the windshield as he drove all
the way across town to her apartment in
the early hours of the morning and then
there was this scene that awaited him as
he stepped through the door the mess
that had been of her kitchen covering
the floor smeared up the walls even
dripping off the ceiling it also stayed
there as Avi debated with his daughter
about what they should do next she was
crying begging for her dad's help
suggesting that they should clean the
place from top to bottom and hide any
evidence scattered around the apartment
laying in his cell all those months
later he sometimes wondered why he said
no to that idea instead they came up
with a story a falsified version of
events Avi made Kali swear to stick to
it no matter what and threw heavy sobs
she agreed then after they'd been over
every detail and had it perfect Avi got
back in his car and drove to the nearest
police precinct to turn himself in all
while taking the fall pleading guilty in
court and being sentenced to prison he
reminded himself over and over that he
was doing it for Kali no matter what she
had done whatever accidents had happened
she was still his kid and he would do
anything to protect her but that was
part of what made it sting so bad not
being locked up but not getting to see
her despite making requests after
request Avi was denied visitation rights
when seeing his daughter and knowing she
was alright were the only things that
would have made this struggle easier was
after his 20th request that a guard
informed Avi that he was being moved at
first he assumed movement to another
part of the prison maybe with more lack
security and the right to see Kali but
they didn't mean moved they meant
transferred into the care of an
organization Avi came to know as the SCP
Foundation it was different here the
kind of people he was locked up with as
a member of d-class personnel were some
of the most heinous criminals on the
planet but there was something else
going on something weirder Avi would
overhear Whispers and rumors from the
other d-classes they'd talk of
experiments conducted by the foundation
with them as the Lab Rats
d-14164 the researcher greeted him as he
was pulled into a side room flanked on
all sides by armed Foundation guards
yours is quite the interesting case no
priors no criminal affiliations of any
kind hardly any family to testify to
your innocence and yet what you did now
that takes some guts if you pardon the
pun so it's all true then Avi replied
solemnly you're here to say you want to
experiment on me I wouldn't call it an
experiment per se the researcher smiled
smugly let's use the word expedition as
a nicer ring to it don't you think an
expedition to where he asked I'm afraid
I can't tell you that then I won't go
Avi Shrugged listen closely d-14164 the
SCP Foundation has
well let's say a considerable influence
across the globe what we're asking you
to agree to is involvement and possibly
one of the most dangerous operations we
have ever conducted now as unappealing
as that might sound allow me to sweeten
the deal should you say yes agree to
take part and follow our instructions
then you might find that the
foundation's influence may be rather
beneficial to you should you survive the
researcher paused to push a document
across the table close enough for Avi to
read a clean record that one nasty
mistake wiped clean for good on top of
that an immediate release and a new
identity you'd have a second chance Mr
Garrett both of you and your daughter
would and what if I say no obvious
bluntly well that's your prerogative the
researcher replied and we won't be able
to detain you after releasing evidence
of your innocence so you'll be free no
matter what oh although your daughter
will of course be remanded into custody
given that she is guilty maybe once we
get her move to d-class she might be
more willing to cooperate than her dear
old dad under the table avi's hands were
shaking with rage he clenched his fist
so furiously that the Cuffs felt tighter
around his wrists the hate in his eyes
was palpable as he glared at the
researcher it was bad enough that they
had backed him into a corner put him in
a situation where in saying yes or no
would be equally catastrophic but what
felt worse was that they knew what Kali
had done and they were using that as a
threat taking a deep breath Avi steadied
himself before finally speaking up again
just tell me what you want me to do
instantly he'd felt like he'd been
thrown headfirst into a commotion he
could barely keep up with no sooner had
he said that Avi had been LED Away by a
team of foundation guards while the
researcher followed rattling off vague
information about the Expedition Guided
by the armed escort into another room
Avi was flocked by more Foundation staff
strapping electronic equipment over to
the outside of his orange prisoner GARP
one piece of it was to monitor his heart
rate another was a portable camera to
record his surroundings although those
were among the few details that he was
actually able to catch during all the
activity Avi couldn't help but notice
how nobody had even mentioned just where
he was meant to be going on this
Expedition just that the foundation
wanted to keep a close eye on him while
he was there you still haven't told me
exactly where it is I'm meant to be
going he finally spoke up or how I'm
getting there all in good time the head
researcher replied so far the only
detail you need to be aware of is this
it's dangerous a particularly hostile
environment so like a war zone aviast
the researcher smiled but to themselves
as if there was something funny about
the question and lack of understanding
it conveyed avi's attention was quickly
turned to another d-class wearing a
similar d-class uniform to him the staff
began preparing the second convict in
the same room although without nearly as
much gear as they did of an Avi I
thought I was the only one going on this
trip he stated ah don't worry that's
just the lure the researcher explained
though it only raised more questions
they won't be accompanying you it was
then Avi was led out of the prep room
and walked through the foundation
facility the place was a hive of
activity as well as noise there were
alien shrieks and whales monstrous
sounds emanating from deep in the
building muffled only slightly
underneath thick layers of concrete and
heavy steel doors on top of that there
were screams too distinctly human sounds
of pain and fear Avi tried to ignore it
as he was instructed to keep walking
feeling almost nostalgic for the Clank
of metal bars back at his old cell he
had been anticipating being taken out of
the facility towards maybe a helipad or
Runway where an aircraft would be
waiting to fly him out to his
undisclosed destination in fact even a
dock with a moored boat would have been
more within the realm of what he
expected but instead he was taken deeper
and deeper into the foundation's
sprawling complex passing testing areas
and containment levels through winding
corridors until Avi was told to stop in
front of a heavy door that held a
containment area Beyond he couldn't help
but notice that the door itself looked
brand new like it had only just been
installed meanwhile the frames
surrounding it had traces of discoloring
and damage almost as if something
corrosive had melted away the previous
door hence the replacement this is it
Avi asked confused but still trying to
nudge more information out of the
foundation's staff you want me to do an
expedition within your own building yes
and no the head researcher replied still
giving NYX to no useful details now this
is important once you get to your
destination we need you to figure out
how to get back to us you do that and
you'll have your freedom your daughter
and your second chance surely to get
back I can just open up this door again
the prisoner said that garnered a slight
chuckle from the researcher again
seeming to find avi's lack of
understanding amusing
oh d-14164 if only it was that simple
the door opened with a heaving metallic
Creak and Avi was unceremoniously pushed
inside by the guards staggering inside
catching himself before he lost his
balance and fell over he almost turned
back to start slamming his fists against
the now sealed entrance he would have
were not for the sight of something
oozing out of the wall directly in front
of him Avi step closer to inspected but
withdrew his hand as he noticed thick
black droplets leaking onto the floor
the substance hissed as it made contact
with the ground like it was burning
through corroding whatever it came into
contact with keeping himself from
touching it Avi leaned in to get a
closer look and found the grotesque face
of
scp-106 looking back at him a spindly
decrepit hand reached out of the gooey
puddle and grabbed the orange material
of avi's jumpsuit pulling at the Garment
with enough strength to tug his entire
body forward in a blind panic Avi tried
to swipe the old man's rotting arm away
feeling an intense burning almost like a
chemical scalding his skin as the same
black ooze burned through his clothing
and started to singe his chest another
hand shot forward out of the puddle on
the wall a clawed thumb puncturing avi's
side he screamed in pain as he felt the
blistering digit Pierce into him while
the rest of the fingers pulled him
closer still to the wall using the hole
in his side like a handle the stench of
his own burning flesh mixed with the air
of rotting Decay that scp-106 brought
with it everywhere the decaying face of
the old man peered through the black
slime on the wall its mouth locked in a
sadistic Sinister grin as Avi found
himself pulled inside it almost felt
like he had fallen asleep in the bathtub
and woke up gasping and sputtering just
having narrowly avoided drowning except
now he was waking up in an entire fairly
different space the transition there
having done little to deal the pain of
his injuries sitting up as he arrived in
his new dark and desolate surroundings
Avi gripped his side and winced at the
Searing pain then the sun smell of
burning plastic crawled up his nostrils
and downed the back of his throat most
of the equipment the foundation had
strapped onto him was melting the heart
rate monitor and Camera corroding
covered in more of that black sludge
standing up gritting his teeth through
the pain of his wounds Avi quickly
removed the devices as carefully as he
could it was far beyond caring about the
foundation's Expedition right now he
just wanted to get back out of wherever
the hell this place was checking over
his shoulder the Slick corrosive puddle
he'd been pulled through was already
gone at any rate Avi didn't particularly
like the idea of going back that way so
was relieved although he'd soon find out
that relief was perhaps misplaced he had
barely a few moments to examine his
surroundings not that there was much he
could see besides and endless dark
corridors and the withered figure of the
old man it had reappeared looking like
it was far off in the distance before in
a split second the gap between scp-106
and Avi had closed the creature tilted
its bald skeletal head as it looked at
him and he got a full unobscured Glimpse
at its sunken eyes and face locked in a
Perpetual lipless grin the rotting
wrinkly flesh of the old man's body was
oozing more and more of that dark
disgusting mucus droplets of it landing
on avi's clothing and burning holes
right through one hand still applying
pressure to his side I'll be turned and
tried to run as far and fast as his body
was able if getting away was his sole
objective he wanted out as quick as
possible anything to get away from the
nightmarish creature he had now found
himself trapped with running didn't seem
to work though he was sure he had made
it at least a few feet the old man was
still standing behind him but looked to
be at more of a distance that was until
noticed his legs they were running
backwards each step he had taken away
from scp-106 was being reversed rebound
like on an old VHS tape bringing him
back closer and closer to the creature's
clutches its claws pushed painfully
through avi's back as It reversed time
right back to the point where he had
turned to run away as the old man
reached through him more of that burning
acidic pain started eating away at its
captive d-class prey with Avi letting
out a pain scream it wasn't until
several minutes in that he realized
something that hurt almost just as bad
scp-106 could have killed him in an
instant that much was clear but it
hadn't it had chosen not to instead it
was torturing him prolonging the pain
Avi was experiencing because it wanted
him to suffer with all its strength
scp-106 hurled him several feet until
avi's burning corroded body collided
with a hard surface a wall with a loud
crack the old man then manipulated time
within his pocket Dimension causing Avi
to fly backward through the air back
into the creature's corrosive grip it
allowed time to keep winding back
undoing all the damage it had done so
far as much as Avi was relieved to be
rid of the Searing pain he was in a sick
worry deep in the pit of his stomach
told him that this wasn't an act of
Mercy the old man just wanted to make
him suffer all over again he lost track
of how long it went on for
scp-106 taking sickly and hurting his
captive only to reverse the time within
the pocket Dimension and do it all again
each time felt just like the first made
worse by the fact that Avi never had a
chance to get used to the pain to become
numb to it instead every moment the
torture started was just like the first
time in fact it technically was
screaming in agony Avi had no clue if he
had been there for hours days months or
even years at any time passed at all how
many times had the old man done this to
him only to reverse time and do it all
over again letting the pain begin Anew
every few tries the old man would
release Avi for a moment but once again
it was never done out of any sense of
Mercy or kindness it was so it could
hunt him still Avi ran every time as far
and fast as he could searching every
corner of that dark desolate place for
some kind of a way out a portal home
another one of those corrosive black
puddles a big door with exit written on
it in big letters but instead all he
found was
scp-106 or rather the old man found him
it was hunting him again Avi had no idea
how many times this made panting he
slowed to a halt trying to catch his
breath reaching out in the dark he put a
hand against a nearby hard surface a
wall then felt a crack under his hand
examining closer although he could
barely see it Javi could feel with
absolute certainty that this wall had
been damaged just a little it was the
same one the exact same wall he had been
thrown against who knew how long ago but
the point was it was still cracked from
where his body had hit it even after the
old man had reversed time to hurt Avi
over and over again the damage had
stayed he had no way of knowing if it
would work or how long it would take but
it might have been away out desperately
off he slammed his fist against the wall
feeling pain shooting through his
fingers and up into his arm as it
collided with a solid surface nothing
changed winding back the other arm he
hid it again still nothing Avi could
hear the old man shuffling closer behind
him could sense his hands reaching out
closer to torture him again he let it
happen striking one last blow against
the wall before it finally reached him
and the pain began once more only to be
reversed so that scp-106
could do it again but now he had a goal
each time the creature rewound time and
undid all the damage to its captive's
body Avi went looking for that same wall
feeling across every surface until he
reached it again the damage was still
there only a tiny crack for now but time
despite being under the old man's
control in this pocket Dimension was on
avi's side whenever he made it back to
the wall he started to punch it again
pounding one fist against it after the
other he didn't relent despite the pain
that caused him he told himself it would
be worth it if it meant a way out even
the times when the bones in his hands
broke and he was flimsily striking at
the cracked wall with shattered fingers
he didn't stop it would be worth it it
had to be no matter how long it took he
would gradually chip away at the wall
more and more every time scp-106 would
find Avi and when it did it would hurt
him the pain he'd put himself through
trying to break down the wall helped no
some of the torture before the old man
reset everything again then the hunt
began again and Avi went back to making
his gradual dent in the wall the whole
time he remembered he was doing it for
Kali for his freedom and a fresh start
until eventually it stopped Avi had no
idea how many times he'd struck the wall
but it had been enough to Start Tumbling
through it slightly both hands bloody
and broken again but this time the old
man didn't appear it had stopped
screaming in Rage Avi started throwing
himself at the indented wall trying
desperately to Chip Away more completely
unaware that scp-106 had left him alone
in its pocket Dimension back in their
facility the foundation had lost contact
with avi's recording devices over three
hours ago at which point they had
initiated their recall protocol injuring
the d-class they had chosen as a lure
sure enough the old man had reappeared
from his pocket Dimension following the
pain screams to come and finish the lure
off there was no sign of Avi and with
his sign the head researchers simply
noted down
scp-106 pocket Dimension Escape test
result test inconclusive now go check
out scp-106 Containment Breach and
scp-106 caused a school lockdown for
stories of a few other situations where
unsuspecting victims found themselves
being hunted by the old man and whether
or not they too live to talk about it